Alhamdulillah. Continuing
[Silence]
in
in the chapter regard in the book of
fasting the chapter regarding upon on
whom fasting is obligated. We discussed
yesterday some of the parameters of
travel
and we mentioned that it is not a
distance thing. It is not a duration
thing.
And now we want to apply some of these
rulings to fasting.
First of all,
at what point
is a person considered to be a traveler?
What is travel?
Travel
is not been defined
clearly.
It has not been defined
or quantified
in the Quran and Sunnah as being A or B.
And so travel has been left to the
customs of the people. Whatever is
considered to be travel amongst the
people of that time and place an area,
this is what travel is because it it
changes. If we were to quantify it by a
duration, if we were to quantify it by a
difficulty, if we were to quantify it by
a distance, these things change with the
change of technology. They change with
the change of customs. They change with
the change of even geography. And so
really
travel is
whatever is considered to be travel in
that time and place amongst that
particular people anywhere anywhere.
And so whatever the people generally
consider to be travel that is what
travel is. And when a person undertakes
that they are a traveler by the def
definition of the Quran and Sunnah and
this is an important principle. It's
actually a principle that all of the
have come to a consensus upon and that
is
anything that has not been quantified by
the Quran and Sunnah
then it is
left that way in order to be applied to
the customs of the time and place where
those
you know those rulings are being
implemented. The Quran and Sunnah it has
been left this open-ended purposely
and that is so that it will fit every
people and every time and every place.
So,
so a travel and a traveler and travel
distance or what have you is whatever
the people of a particular time and
place view to be travel and it is travel
right. Imagine with me for instance if
here in
Tucson,
imagine with me Phoenix.
Now imagine if we customarily
were a kind of satellite town to Phoenix
and all of us, most of us worked in
Phoenix. Okay. And so the custom of
people here is that every morning most
of the town of or the city of Tucson
empties out and goes to Phoenix every
day. This is just a normal thing. We've
got trains that go there. We've got
everything that goes there. It's it's
it's almost the two cities are one.
Would we consider that to be travel?
No, we wouldn't consider that to be
travel in that instance. Now imagine
with me that we had another place that
was closer than Phoenix.
Pay attention here. The hypothetical
that we're giving here is we've got
Phoenix. This is a satellite town for
Phoenix. We're always going to Phoenix
every day. And then imagine with me
another town that was closer than
Phoenix, but we never go there. We only
go there when we are going out of our
way and traveling.
It is possible that the closer place is
considered to be travel whereas the
further place is considered to be not
travel. Is that strange? No. Because
again this goes back to the customs
of the people, the place and the time.
And so for our intents and purposes now
if we come back to the the reality of
the situation, Phoenix is not a place
that we usually go every day. This is
not a satellite town to Phoenix. Phoenix
is what 100 miles away or something like
that. And yes, Phoenix is considered to
be travel for us here in Tucson.
because it is a place that is out of the
way. It's a place that is. And so the
point is is that travel is not defined
by the Quran and Sunnah. It's been left
open-ended purposely. Why? So that it
can apply to each place and each time.
Now when it comes to the rulings of
fasting,
the mere intention of travel allows a
person to break his fast.
So if a person were to have planned to
travel today, they don't have to leave
before they can break their fast. They
are permitted to break their fast before
they leave as long as they have the
earnest intention that they are going to
travel. So I wake up, I'm going to go to
Phoenix for the day or I'm going to go
to Flagstaff or whatever it is. And so I
break my fast. I have breakfast at my
home etc. and I get in my car and I
leave. This is permissible. Not the case
with with prayer. With salah it is the
opposite. The intention of travel is not
enough to break a per to to join
prayers. A person must have embarked on
his trip
and a person must leave the city and be
out of the parameters of the city that
they are traveling from. At that point
they can start to shorten their
prayers.
So
u in
There is a narration in which
in the time of his
was traveling and he had his entourage
and his companions with him etc. and
they were leaving
the city. This is after the had moved to
Iraq and the time for
came in
and they passed by a hus a hus
is a shack. A shack a little shack.
And this
was on the outskirts of the city and
someone a shepherd or whatever was
living in this
right.
And
when the time of came in, they stopped
to make salah. And he said,
he said, "Had it not been for this
shack,
we would have shortened and joined our
prayers." What does he mean by that?
This hosa is part of the city. It's part
of the parameters of the city, right?
And so he understands that traveling and
shortening the prayer and joining the
prayers only occurs once a person
leaves the
parameters of the city. So the scholars
tell us the
shortening of prayers and the joining
of prayers begins once a person passes
the last buildings which are part of the
city. Right? The last buildings which
are part of the city, this is considered
to be travel. And it's very
interesting when you look at things like
travel and and how they apply to each
place and each time. And it's honestly
very thankful that Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala had left it open-ended and left
it to the customs of the people in New
York City.
They New York City is five burrows.
Okay. So these five,
they're basically cities. All these five
are connected together and they all make
up one city. You could get on a train
and go from one burrow to the next and
if it's a slow day or a weekend or the
train is running local. You could be on
that train for hours and you're not
considered to be a traveler, not amongst
their customs, right? And you could get
on a train and go to New Jersey and you
are considered to be a traveler and it
is shorter than going to Queens from
Manhattan. Why? Because it is all back
to the customs. It is not an issue of
duration. It's not an issue of distance.
It's an issue of customs. Right? So when
it comes to fasting, you are permitted
to break your fast as a traveler.
When are you permitted to break your
fast as a traveler? Once you have the
intention of traveling. Once you are
planning to travel that day. Right? And
this is in line with the patterns of
the Quran and Sunnah. Why? Because
unlike salah
where you can make it anywhere and you
can make it at any time, fasting is an
issue of eating.
So if you're going to travel,
there's not, you know, especially at the
time of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam, there's not just a restaurant
everywhere you stop. There's not a place
everywhere you stop. You need to eat
before you leave. Otherwise, you're
going to miss that meal. And so, Islam
has permitted that a person break his
fast upon having the intention of
traveling. Whereas, when it comes to
prayer, a person can make prayer
anywhere. They can make prayer anytime.
Therefore, a person must be engaged in
travel and have started his travel and
have emerged from the the parameters
of his city or town in order to start
with his shortening of his prayers
and joining of his prayers. Now these
are the five points of criteria for
those whom fasting is obligated upon.
Okay Muslim
right those are the five. Now we
discussed these in the past few days in
detail but now what is the difference
between knowledge and imitation?
Imitation is what is the difference
between knowledge and the scholars have
all agreed
that aid
is not a person of knowledge.
A mid
is not a person of knowledge. If I were
to read the words of a scholar
without evidences from the Quran and
Sunnah and follow that ruling that he
gives me, this is called this is
imitation. I'm imitating what he said.
But this is not knowledge. Even if I've
read a million fata, as long as I do not
have the evidence. Evidence is the
difference between a scholarship and
is the difference between knowledge and
what is the difference between aid and a
scholar? A scholar knows the evidences.
Aid does not know the evidences. So we
want to now go and take these five
things that we just heard from Ali who
just read to us from
we want to take these from the realm of
into the realm of knowledge. So we want
to mention the evidences for each of
these five points which we will do
[Arabic recitation]